nothing is left if Abu Zeid eBay's Hut
it caught fire during the night this
bliss oblivion this is my us in 2014 CD
Bay came to Spain from Ivory Coast to
find work he ended up in this slum near
the town of lepe Andalusia along with up
to a thousand others fires occur
frequently due to the flammable building
materials gas canisters and 40 degrees
Celsius heat
[Music]
because money you need to peel plastic
oh you know you need to buy many teen to
face one Rhino would be trying to look
for Teresa to to come to billion a booze
dream of a better life in Europe has
become a nightmare
he has no residence permit and now he
has no home he can only work illegally
on one of the many fruits and vegetable
plantations you don't have no right to
work here you know you don't have no
money
to see that or live in a house to see
that every month you need to build him a
house money you know you don't have one
his friend Mona of a [ __ ] say is in the
same position except he's a newcomer in
Spain having recently arrived from
Senegal he lives in this Hut he says the
routes taken by refugees to Europe are
always changing currently entering
Europe via the western Mediterranean
seems to be the safest route from Libya
to Italy has lots of problems it's
almost like a war you can get killed so
now many of us are coming to Spain
through Morocco
the numbers of migrants coming into
Spain are currently at a peak and Spain
is still dealing with the effects of its
economic crisis making the rising
numbers of refugees a political issue
based on desperado but they have to be
pretty desperate to take on the journey
in the first place but I don't think
they should bring them here they should
help them to do better in their own
countries I guess 10 kimonos
in Spain's new government is taking a
lenient stance with migrants but the
right-wing conservative opposition is in
disagreement and the Spaniards are
worried going on demography on so many
immigrants could cause us problems
that's just how it is
Spain is a country with high
unemployment there's just not enough
jobs for so many people
other Spaniard see things differently
Antonio Abad volunteers for an aid
organization and supports migrants like
abou any way he can he helps Abu plant
vegetables and takes care of red tape
Antonio sees the refugees as an economic
factor the plantations in the region
couldn't get by without them I feel I
get that persona i thinkI thanks to
these people many others are getting
rich the immigrants live off with little
money they can earn so their cheap labor
they have to put up with everything and
never complain Antonio thinks they can
be proud of what they've accomplished so
far but most of them are ashamed to be
living in a slum in Europe they don't
want their families to see them living
here in these conditions that's logical
you can understand that I don't think
they ever lived like this in Africa
Abu Sidibe is not ashamed on the
contrary he wants people to know what's
really happening in Europe and he's not
ready to give up on his dream of a
better life
[Music]
got apni a move in Morocco to entire ESP
now I'm living yet some China I'll go to
the work to get some more money to send
it to my family in Africa to help myself
here you know man I'm new I'm T died for
my future
Oh [ __ ] India eventually once he's
saved enough money abou Sidibe intends
to return to the Ivory Coast my son
needs me he says all of Africa needs us
but that's in the future right now he's
got to figure out where he can sleep
tonight